GRADY POWELL: John, Michael,
gentlemen, congratulations.
The two of you have made it
through the first two rounds
of our competition
and are moving forward
into the final
round, where you're
heading back to your
home forges to build
an iconic weapon from history.
The is the the largest blade
we have ever asked bladesmiths
to make in the final round.
Gentlemen, in four days,
you will have to build this.
[sighing]
The Grote Pier sword.
NARRATOR: During
the 16th century,
a larger-than-life warrior
in the Netherlands known
to the locals as Grote
Pier, or the Giant Pier,
wielded this massive
sword in battle.
Pier's size made him the
subject of folklore and legend.
But the physical size of
his sword speaks for itself.
The 15-pound, nearly
7-foot tall sword
is the largest European sword
ever to be used in combat.
As a mercenary and
pirate, Grote Pier
is believed to have wielded
this weapon with ease,
delivering devastating blows to
any enemy that got in his way.
And it can be seen
today at the Frieze
Museum in the Netherlands.
GRADY POWELL: Now,
guys, good luck.
You have four days to
complete your massive swords.
We will see you then.
[music playing]
JOHN: My name is John
Simons from Indianapolis.
I have a three
years bladesmithing.
Most of that's all self-taught.
I love doing this.
Some people want to
go to Disney World.
I want to come here.
This is my vacation, so I'm
really looking forward to it.
This blade is so long, I can
only heat up about eight inches
at a time, press it.
Just a very repetitive process.
Prepping for this quench is
going to take a little time.
I have three forges.
I can get nearly all that
sword in the forges at once.
This is a super-sized
quench tank.
Never used it yet.
We're going to
test it out today.
Quenching this-- I've
never had to climb
five rungs of a ladder.
Everything needs to go right
because there's not enough time
to do it all over again.
Hope for the best.
I didn't feel anything
abnormal when it quenched.
It is hard.
And most importantly,
it is straight.
All the components are there.
They just need some finishing
touches and put an edge on it.
The blade, it is 100% complete.
I'm exhausted, but inside,
it feels wonderful.
The mother of all swords.
MICHAEL: My name is Michael
Dillon, 54 years old.
Been forging for 30 years.
I started making knives for
props in the movie industry.
I'm pretty confident but
worried my pants may fall down.
That's why I have a
belt and suspenders.
I'm used to building big stuff.
Some of my sculptures
weigh up to 6,500 pounds.
So this is in the realm of
what I'm used to working on.
My quench tank's buried
six feet in the Earth.
Here we go up this ladder.
This thing is huge.
Guard, done.
Pommel's done.
The plan is to grind a pound
and a half up this blade.
Everything's coming out.
Nice shape.
And I'm going to start
the finish of the blade,
and the guard, and the pommel.
I'm really happy with it.
I really got to hit
something with this.
I just can't let it pass.
Nasty.
DOUG: Bladesmiths,
welcome to the KEAL test.
John, you are up first.
Are you ready?
- You know I'm ready.
- All right.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, John.
Let's talk about
your sword here.
What I like is that you use
a nice, hefty counterbalance
because despite being a
heavy sword like this,
it's wieldable.
The edges are sharp.
It cut deeply.
I like that the guard
also is not so massive
that it gets in the way.
And overall, it will KEAL.
- Awesome.
- All right, Michael your turn.
You ready, sir?
- Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Michael.
That's a beast.
That's a beautiful beast.
Now, your edge is sharp.
That really cuts deep
into the pig carcass.
It is a nice, heavy
weight but controllable.
And more importantly,
it will KEAL.
Thank you, sir.
DAVE: Gentlemen, it's time
for our strength test,
the sheet metal chop.
Now, there are three layers
of 20-gauge sheet metal
in each one of these things.
And, John, you're up first.
Are you ready for this?
- I am.
OK.
[music playing]
All right, John.
Very nice job on this sword.
It's got a good weight to it.
The blade itself, and there
are some slight rolls.
But it's still plenty sharp.
One comment I might have is
that the blades lean enough
that it's very flexible.
When I pick it up,
that tip kind of drops
maybe three inches of flex.
You start to swing that
blade, you don't know
where that tip's going to go.
It's flopping around.
But it did its job.
Well done.
- Thank you.
DAVE: All right, Michael,
are you ready for this?
Give it hell.
DAVE: Oh, good because
this is so much fun.
[laughs]
[music playing]
All right, Michael, balance
point, right where I freaking
want it.
It's a little bit
more of a firm blade.
It doesn't quite wiggle as much.
As far as damage, just
the very edge is rolled.
But I would not drag my
finger down that edge.
It would still open me up.
Knocked it out of the park.
Well done.
Thank you.
DOUG: All right, bladesmiths.
This is a sharpness test-- the
watermelon and water jug slice.
John, you're up first.
Are you ready for this?
- I am.
- All right.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, John.
Let's talk about
your blade here.
The edge, it cut
the first watermelon
cleanly and then just wobbled.
There's so much wobble in this.
As Dave said, there's just
so much flex in this blade,
you don't know where
the tip is going to go.
And that's what happened
in the watermelon slice.
On the water jugs, clean cut.
Even the tops are still there
wondering what happened.
Overall, your Grote
Pier, it will cut.
Thank you.
DOUG: Michael, your turn.
Are you ready?
- You bet.
All right.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Michael, let's
talk about your blade here.
First up, on a watermelon
slice, much easier.
Not much flex on the blade here.
It's easy to just
keep it and let
it drop and let it do its work.
And it cuts all the way through.
On the water jug
slice, it did cut.
Overall, your
sword, it will cut.
Thank you.
That was pretty rad.
All right, gentlemen.
In this super-sized
competition, we
gave you a task on a scale
unlike anything we've
ever seen before in this forge.
And the blades you brought
back here impressed all of us.
But as you know,
only one of you can
take home the title of
"Forged in Fire" champion
and get that check for $10,000.
And the judges did
make a final decision.
Today's "Forged in Fire"
champion is Michael.
Congratulations.
John, you gave us an
unbelievable blade.
But it missed by just this much.
And Dave is going
to tell you why.
DAVE: John, this
decision really came down
to the extreme
flexibility of your blade.
That's why we're letting you go.
GRADY POWELL: John, you
are an unbelievable smith.
But unfortunately, your time
in this competition has ended.
I'm going to have
to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
I had a blast.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, John.
GRADY POWELL: Well,
Michael, that makes you
the "Forged in Fire" champion.
You're taking home
a check for $10,000.
Well done, man.
Woo.
I'm "Forged in Fire" champion.
This is the first blade I've
ever forged of this size.
I'm very proud of
my performance.
Very important to me
to share the craft,
and to educate people, and
make some badass swords.
[music playing]